2023 and in Esports the word franchising
is basically a curse franchise leagues
guarantee spots for paying franchisee
teams but not all Esports leagues work
that way now in 2023 people are starting
to blame the franchising model for all
sorts of things so I thought let's take
a quick flyover of the issue where did
franchising come from how did it do and
should we even keep trying this thing
now
hey guys before we get into the video
just wanted to give you a quick reminder
to like the video if you enjoy the video
and to subscribe and ring the
notification Bell if you haven't already
I really like putting together these
kinds of videos so let me know down in
the comments if this video was useful
for you or maybe for somebody else you
know cheers okay so for this video we're
gonna go back to 2012. back then most
Esports that you would be familiar with
operated under an open circuit format
where teams could qualify themselves for
tournaments travel to attend them and
then normally there would be one or two
championships based however far apart
more structured leagues that involved
Partnerships have been tried before
including the ill-fated CGS but the
circuit model kind of outlived it now if
you watch Call of Duty or Halo back in
the day you know exactly what I'm
talking about a group of guys could
qualify for an event maybe they do well
enough to earn that Dr Pepper sponsor
ship or maybe they get picked up by a
big gaming work this model had tons of
benefits for players but maybe foremost
among them was the fact that they could
just self-organize and then reap the
benefits of that Organization for
themselves and it's also pretty easy to
see why developers would like this model
too they don't have to do much they
don't have to hire much staff and
tournament organizers simply operate
with their blessing for the most part
basically the game is getting talked
about it has a chance to make headlines
be in the popular culture and the
developer didn't have to do too much but
as Esports grew this model in particular
started to see some pushback from some
interested parties firstly the developer
was exercising only limited control over
their product and to be clear I'm not
saying that they couldn't exercise
control over it more that they were just
choosing not to take for example season
one and two of League of Legends sure
there were World Championships both
years in freak's basement but the rest
of the year is mostly circuit type
events like iems and dream hacks now
that change in 2013 when season 3
introduced regionally based leagues for
North America and Europe but the spots
in those leagues were still subject to
Performance this relegation meant that
there were always Stakes even for the
lowest ranked teams in a league because
if you didn't do well enough and you got
sent to the promotion tournament you got
relegated you weren't playing in the
league anymore now to sum this seemed to
make an already existing problem even
worse namely the revolving door of
player names and team names that tends
to happen when you have an open circuit
and open qualifications the last main
problem in the eyes of the developers
with this model and maybe the one that
gets the most attention is that Esports
could have been doing better it could
have been bigger maybe and if it did
that then the advertising demographic of
view viewers who watch Esports which was
mostly young and then primarily male
viewers could be monetized by the
developer through advertisements or
promotions or whatever and let's also
not forget streaming was starting to pop
off people were becoming overnight stars
and there was this feeling that Esports
could have a real future as a form of
entertainment so after 2012 we start to
see Riot assert more direct control over
their leagues and for the next five
years the level of play and the level of
the entertainment itself continue to
climb other companies were skeptical of
this new shift notably valve who
basically kept to the open circuit model
in both Counter-Strike and DOTA 2. Dota
2 had the international a massive barn
burner tournament at the end of the year
and both games had officially sanctioned
Majors but they didn't go into the
league format like Riot did by 2015 it's
clear that riots bet on their leagues
has paid off the game itself is doing
incredibly well viewership is good and
there are some big names looking to
spend money in the league even with the
threat of relegation though I want to
note that the spots in these
unfranchised Regional leagues were still
worth money some organizations figured
it out early like Cloud9 and they
regularly fielded rosters of either
aspiring or perhaps bench Pros to earn
these spots and sell them now there were
big names starting to spend money in
these leagues including paying for
regional spots for example but there was
an increasing feeling that the idea that
one of these spots could just evaporate
if the players lost it was kind of a
problem to continued investment so
during this time there were some big
names from sports and entertainment
splashing money on League of Legends but
there was also this feeling that it
wasn't a great investment if you know
your players might lose maybe something
unforeseen happens you have to find a
replacement and your team gets relegated
and you lose your spot and your
investment blizzard also realized this
and they targeted their new game
OverWatch for a flagship Esports
transformation the new OverWatch League
was supposed to do nothing less than
compete with the NFL NBA and MLB now
what we saw over the next few years was
a closing off of major Esports by some
wealthy investors the money those
investors use went to pay player
salaries staff salaries other kinds of
overhead and in some cases like the
OverWatch League those organizations
even agreed to build real-world physical
facilities to host home and away games
for the new league the problem with
these franchise leagues is that it
wasn't immediately clear where the
consistent Revenue stream would actually
come from and it wasn't until we got to
2020 and the pandemic that the cracks in
this model really started to show
broadcast deals rely partially on
viewership which was a struggle for
OverWatch league and as the scandals
piled up for Activision Blizzard it
seemed like advertisers too were wary of
the company's reputation in 2023
OverWatch League teams reportedly
approached the league itself asking for
some kind of fiscal relief in the face
of what they were experiencing and they
got it their outstanding franchise fees
have been waived and that's a solution
that might even be applied to the Call
of Duty League which also launched in
2020. we have to be clear that we don't
know exactly what will happen with the
OverWatch League it's possible it will
still have franchisees but what does
seem clear is that the structure of the
league will undergo some substantial
changes to accommodate this new reality
things weren't quite as catastrophic in
the nalcs now just called the LCS but
even there it's clear that the intent
was to drive costs down specifically
Riot games axed a requirement for teams
to field an academy roster and that
upset the players union and kicked off a
dispute now that dispute has been
resolved the season has been salvaged
we've got a whole video on that if you
want to check it out but again let's
recognize that the reason this whole
dispute started was a desire to reduce
costs for franchise teams League
franchising which started in 2017 and
then spread to other regions has been a
much easier pill to swallow for fans but
that doesn't mean it's perfect for me
it's my opinion of course but it seems
undeniable that the removal of
relegation has damaged the level of play
in League of Legends especially if you
go back and look at those first couple
years under the system you'll see there
were some Free Riders who were either
unwilling or incapable of Fielding a
team that was any good and yeah League
of Legend Legends franchising seems
pretty good compared to whatever
blizzard did and I didn't talk about
Starcraft 2 in this video because I
didn't have time nor did I talk about my
beloved Heroes of the Storm which had
kind of a weird franchising test run
towards the end of its life but what
about valve's decision to keep their
Esports in more or less the open circuit
model well it paid off and
Counter-Strike in my opinion made the
absolute best of that situation by
having all these tournament organizers
with different tones different Talent
lineups and really just different
approaches to Counter-Strike but even in
the open circuit format of
Counter-Strike there were people who
wanted to close it off for themselves
according to a report from Esports
journalist Richard Lewis last month
valve told teams of the Paris major that
Leagues with partnered teams were not
part of the developers preferred vision
for the game's competitive structure
both ESL and blast big tournament
operators have their own leagues that
have these guaranteed Spa thoughts for
partner teams valve is against that and
you know what they're right we should
always have the best teams playing and
it's up to the players and the teams
themselves to earn those spots and show
that they belong there so some franchise
leagues seem to have crashed if not
exactly burned and others seem to be
kind of doing okay but trying to figure
out the best way to rein and costs and
make this thing work consistently and I
guess appropriately for everyone and far
from suddenly just making Esports
magically bigger than the NFL overnight
it seems like these things mostly just
spent a lot of money but listen as a
North American Esports fan who cares way
more about the quality of play than the
investors or whatever the back half of
last decade pretty much belonged to
valve I'm not minimizing the stories in
League of Legends or perhaps your
favorite esport I'm a strong believer
that there are great stories in all
Esports to be honest but we got two
beautiful games in CS go and Dota 2 and
players were able to make it on their
own terms it wasn't a Utopia or anything
obviously but having that hunger that
drive to win that fear of falling out of
relevance made it so much more
compelling I feel like the spirit of
Esports is tied to this idea that any
one of us could grind and find our own
ceiling then once we find it we could
grind to try to break through it to
become the best player that we can be
for that reason it's easy to see why a
more open system that favors competition
will give us the best thing to watch
right it doesn't mean that other systems
don't have their own benefits or that
this one doesn't have drawbacks for
example in my own day-to-day valve is
notoriously media shy and they can
afford to be because they aren't focused
on keeping their investor Partners happy
or whatever by keeping the game in the
news but I'll gladly take the less
Affair dad who takes us out on cool
trips consistently over the helicopter
dad who really wants to hang out with
Robert Kraft for some reason especially
with the benefit of hindsight
if you get in a helicopter in battle bit
and you start singing fortunate sung Sun
by CCR there's like a 95 chance that the
helicopter pilot will just start
blasting it I'm not kidding it's wild I
hope to do a don't at me on it soon if
this is in the end board maybe let me
know if you want to see that cause
the game is uh game is hot